yes sir
all three of you guys are muslims
honey that's a weird thing to think at
the end of this let's just that's a
weird question in a couple of [ __ ]
levels what that's just
dad
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] yes
i barely one of us is muslim and beyond
him this guy says he's muslim but he
eats pork and [ __ ] white girls and
drinks all the time
i don't need that much
let's
pork
okay
turkey sausage for me thank you very
much
[Laughter]
boy if you were white with a beard i'd
have been terrified
oh my god
this is a homeland security quiz
[Laughter]
yes ma'am your favorite joke my favorite
joke oh
ronnie oh dude dude yeah dude
dangerfield has a great joke he goes uh
i'm not much to look up but i do okay
with the ladies
i'm a rapist
[Applause]
it's a great joke it's good it's a
[ __ ] good joke yo it's a decent
muslim joke
solid
oh [ __ ]
yes sir
[Laughter]
[Applause]
hey buddy hey buddy you'll see
[Applause]
yeah check the news tomorrow monday
morning
[Laughter]
hello buddy stay on twitter you know
what i mean
holy [ __ ]
that was the most muslim you ever been
wow lean in
[Music]
yes ma'am
what would your superpower be if you had
one all three of you
are you the one from alabama
i'd [ __ ] this dude
yeah
i'll take this one right here
yes
did you convert to muslims did you
convert to muslims the [ __ ] would
convert to muslims
it's not like a fun time
none of the rules are good times
you got the multiple wives thing though
that's pretty fun or a nightmare
i'm sorry is my mom here what
kind of judgment doesn't sound like you
follow the rules yo you know i was
saying it's fun that you have multiple
wives and then i was like but imagine if
it's multiple of that [ __ ] that'd be
enough
i'll [ __ ] throw myself off a balcony
i haven't got him
high-rise
have i shot guns yet
yo what kind of federal marshall [ __ ]
y'all got
[ __ ] narcs we're going on a plane
that's our gun
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right there's one right there
this is a spy sent by my wife i know
[ __ ] i'm on to you i'm going to sleep
where are the [ __ ] wires
buddy we're going to the mosque you know
it
we're going to pray for a while
oh my god yes
second favorite joke i don't think
there's a second we can't top the rapist
one yeah yeah let's be honest
i don't think i i'm [ __ ] i just did
jokes for hours yeah
what the [ __ ] do you think i'm doing up
here
hey come on yo
do something
my superpower to go back in time kick
you the [ __ ] out
[Applause]
oh my god dude
oh [ __ ] and then book a flight to
wherever you're
what's up guys thanks for watching the
video if you're a fan just hit subscribe
stop hating what are you waiting for
that way you'll get updated whenever i
put up new videos and we got a lot
coming up
[Music]
you